allez on va passer au dos du jour on va
revenir sur le fait politique du jour
enfin sur le fait du jour d'ailleurs la
nomination de Gabriel Attal Premier
ministre en remplacement d'Élisabeth
borne euh qui va donc voilà qui vaer
travailler avec son frère maintenant euh
qui son frère émil
émil c'est historique parce que c'est le
plus jeune premier ministre français de
l'histoire ouais alors dans un instant
je vais vous donner toutes les infos on
va revenir des images d'archiv même
qu'il est venu ici plusieurs fois hein
Gabriel atttin on a même été prendre un
petit un petit verre à l'époque euh et
on sera surtout avec Marie-Hélène sa
prof préférée et et on aura également
Martin Garagnon un très proche du
Premier ministre qui était à la
passation cet après-midi regardez la
vidéo de la passation ils sont avec nous
juste après c'est parti chère ellisabeth
pendant près de 20 mois c'est la France
de demain que tu as contribué à bâtir t
histoire personnelle tout autant que ton
éthique politique on fait de toi un
exemple cela a été dit ces dernières
heures j'ai pu le lire ou l'entendre le
plus jeune président de la République de
l'histoire nomme le plus jeune premier
ministre de l'histoire je veux pour
conclure m'adresser directement au
français à tous les Français où qu'ils
vivent je veux leur dire qu'ils pourront
toujours compter sur moi leur dire
qu'avec le président de la République
chaque jour chaque minute chaque seconde
leur sera consacré parce qu'il n'y a
rien de plus beau rien de plus fort rien
de plus grand que de servir la France et
les Français je vous
remercie la
T
et allez-y mar marieéè qui est avec nous
marieélè B ancien prof d'histoire g de
gabrielal et on est avec Martin Garagnon
ancien ben trad ancien vous êtes un pote
Gabriel Atal c'est ça un compagnon
politique compagnon politique c'est ça
ça fait longtemps que vous le connaissez
la première fois que j'ai entendu parler
de Gabriel Atal c'est il y a plus de 10
ans à l'époque il était jeune conseiller
au cabinet de Marie Touren ministre de
la Santé de François Hollande ma
meilleure amie travaillait un jour on
déjà ensemble elle me dittion que je te
présente un petit jeune il est
formidable je suis sûr qu'il fera une
super carrière elle me paraît de Gabriel
tal c'est vous avez assisté à la
passation de de pouvoir tout à l'heure
oui c'est un moment quoi ça vous étiez
ému en le voyant c'était très émouvant
c'était un beau moment c'est toujours
des beaux moments des passations à
matigon ce sont des choses assez rares
des moments un peu historiques beaucoup
de respect entre Elisabeth borne et
gabaral et surtout beaucoup de
détermination chez Gabriel mais c'est
quelque chose qui le
caractérise il a été très rapidement
minist de l'éducation il a fait plus
parler de lui que PAP 15
ans à pe di truc de fou par ce qu'il
fait maintenant je crois qu'ils vont des
ch non je sais pas ce qu'il fait
d'ailleurs je sais même pas ce qu'il
faisait quand il ministre deéducation
donc et c'est vrai que est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il il a bien fait parce que
c'est vrai qu'on se dit toujours quand
on ouais c'est parfois un cadeau
empoisonné surtout s'il a des véléités
d'être présidentiel en présidentiable en
en 2027 mais il a eu un mot là-dessus
justement
euh il a dit en gros je j'emporte avec
moi la cause de l'école à matigon donc
c'est un sujet évidemment qui lu tient
très fortement à cœur je pense que
l'action même si elle était courte elle
était extrêmement forte dans ses
annonces dans son engagement il s'est
confié comme jamais aussi engagé comme
jamais gamriel LAL est quelqu'un qui
travaille énormément il faut le savoir
parce que c'est quelque chose qui a été
dit mais qui est une réalité pour
l'avoir vécu pendant plusieurs années
c'est quelqu'un qui s'engage à fond et
qui ne fait pas semblant donc il l'a
fait pour l'éducation je pense qu'il
continuera à suivre de manière
extrêmement précise et proche et avec
force le sujet de l'éducation de l'école
qui est vraiment au cœur aussi des
priorités avec la santé et l'éducation
je pense que c'est des choses sur
lesquelles on fera beaucoup de de choses
prochainement alors on est aussi avec
Marie-Hélène Marie-Hélène merci d'être
avec nous vous étiez vous êtes
l'ancienne prof d'histoire géo du du
nouveau Premier ministre et surtout son
ancienne prof préféré c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est lui-même regardez il y aura
toujours un professeur qui vous marquera
donc vous vous souviendrez et à qui vous
devrez tant de choses pour moi c'est
Madame Bellac professeur d'histoire
géographie c'est cela la beauté de ce
ministère c'est
c'est gentil ça ça ça a dû vous toucher
ah oui beaucoup oui oui alors est-ce que
vous étiez vous comment vous comment
est-ce que vous sentiez que vous étiez
sa prof
préférée-ce non vous savez on le dit
toujours le bétit d'enseignant est un
métier ingra c'est-à-dire que on a des
élèves on en a certains qu'on capte plus
que d'autres avec lesquels on on sent
que le courant passe mieux mais on sait
pas après ce qu'il vont devenir même si
on sent des ambitions bien sûr et puis
on sait pas du tout surtout le le rôle
qu'on a pu jouer dans leur décision et
dans leur avenir travaillez bien ou pas
oui oui bien sûr il travaillait bien il
travaillit bien de manière très
méthodique je pense qu'il avait déjà les
qualités qu'il a maintenant quelqu'un de
rigoureux qui sait où il vaass pardon
dans quelle classe je l'ai eu en
Première et en terminaleou même class
oui oui dans des classes où il était
déjà engagé dans son avenir il était
venu me demander un jour s'il pensait
que c'estes notes et son travail était
suffisant pour intégrer Science Po il a
intégré tout de suite il mention très
bien au bac et il a intégré à l'époque
des
discussions on s pas posé la question on
va pas aller à la fin du cours ça on
sait très bien que ça va pas le faire
quoi non mais c'est vrai c'est fou et et
c'est vrai est-ce que c'était votre
élève préféré ah non pas du tout
ça
faire c'est pas du tout je pou pas le
bler non mais je veux dire on a pas un
élève
préféré non non non non non c'est pas
bien non il y a des élèves qu'on préfère
bien sûr mais il fa parti de vos
préférés fait parti de mes préférés mais
on n pas un élève préféré dans la classe
sinon on pourrait pas s'adresser à tous
et et être capable de de dispenser un
enseignement qui retienne toutes les
attentions ouais donc ouais donc c'est
c'est c'est doncéit un de mes élèves
préférés j'ai l'impression que céit vous
aiez quelqu'un d'autre en élèv préféré
dites-moioi le
nom qui Stéphane Paulin je rigole alors
il était il est non mais en classe
est-ce qu'il était bavard turbulan ou
pas du tout genre vraiment non pas
bavard jamais de problème concentré
jamais de problème ah ouais c'était dans
quel lycée ces qualités non c'était dans
quel lycée ah dans quel lycée à l'École
alsacienne d'cord ah ouais d'cord ces
qualités c'était donc il était
méthodique carré oui méthodique
consciencieux analysant les problèmes
avant de enfin posant les les bonnes
questions et finalement passant à
l'action après je pense qu'il avait déjà
les qualités qu'on lui trouve c'est
exactement c'est amusant parce que c'est
exactement le discours qu' tenu tout à
l'heure lors de la passation a donné sa
méthode il a dit que sa méthode et c'est
ce qu'il applique c'est d'abord de poser
des diagnostics de enfin de poser les
bonnes questions les vrais question et
après passer à l'action donc ça
correspond tout
à Mar il a été ministre de l'Éducation
est-ce que vous aviez quelque chose vous
auriez eu quelque chose à lui demander
quand il était ministre de l'éducation
nationale d'abord je serais bien je
serais pas permise de demander quelque
chose non en tout cas vous non moi j'ai
trouvé que son action à la tête de
l'éducation nationale était formidable
hte c'est pour ça qu'il a été premier
euh ce sont vraiment non mais je veux
dire c'est pas c'est pas seulement la
façon dont il a agi c'est qu'il a remis
au Centre les fondamentaux notamment
c'est une erreur de dire que si on met
tous les élèves dans la même classe au N
de l'égalité on va leur donner la même
chance c'est complètement faux hein donc
ça c'est la réforme de 74 donc il était
temps d'y mettre fin l'idée que bah
quand on n pas acquis les fondamentaux
on passe pas dans la cas suiv
aussi ça me semble évident sinon on
traîne son incapacité tout le temps donc
j'ai été vraiment emballé parce qu'il a
ce qu'il a commencé ce qu'il a entrepris
et qui je pense va d' continuer hein il
y a pas de alors alors justement est-ce
que vous est-ce que vous l'imaginiez
Premier ministre où est-ce que vous es
vous savez on on on n'imagine pas la
carrière de de ses élèves même si on
laissait je savais qu'il voulait faire
de la politique il était poli enfin il
aimait la politique he il était en
terminale qu'il était déjà
chez les socialistes donc c'est c'est un
élève quelqu'un qui avait profondément
un projet politique mais de là je ne
sais pas je fais pas de suplutation sur
ce qui deviendrait un jour alors est-ce
que vous savez combien il va gagner
Gabriel Atal en tant que Premier
ministre au ministère de l'Éducation il
gagné 10647 € brut par mois et
maintenant il va avoir la même
rémunération que le Président de la
République c'est-à-dire un peu plus de
12000 € non 14000 non 17 le
présidentbien 18000 17 15000 non 15
peêtre pas loin
euh00
16000800 non on a dit le même chiffre
mais c'est pas alors bah Vous vous êtes
très loin par
contre c'est 15900 € brut par mois pour
le Premier ministre voilàés est-ce que
vous trouvez que c'est c'est bien moi
c'est bien c'est un bon salaire c'est
pas les plus haut salaires il y a des
dans l'administration il y a des postes
mieux payés mais moi je trouve que c'est
tout à fait satisfaisant qui est mieux
payé que lui les
euhration financière oui son M c'est pas
un très gros salaire c'est pas non par
rapport à au privé ou même au médias oh
atttion bravo marieè marieélène
attention si vous êtes venu pour ça
marieè on va s'arrêter tout de suite non
non non mais non mais honnêtement non
mais attendez pour faire ce métier il
faut il faut être engagé il faut en
avoir envie je veux dire c'est pas une
sé cure c'est quand même vous parliez du
travail qu'ilomli c'est un travail de
tous les instants faut aimer le faire je
crois d'ailleurs que les gens se rendent
pas compte parce même à d'autres niveaux
dans la fonction publique quand on a un
ha poste dans la fonction publique on a
un travail énorme énorme et il y a pas
d'horaire bien s il faut faut être
conscienté moi j'ai toujours dit je vais
continuer à le dire vous avez parlé des
médias les médias c'est privé et c'est
vrai que dans les médias il y a beaucoup
d'argent moi je pense que 15000 € pour
quelqu'un qui fait de la politique moi
je trouve ça beaucoup je trouve ça
beaucoup et rapport aux arguments que
vous avancez la responsabilité la
pénibilité c'est dur c'est c'est de
l'engagement il y a plein de Français
qui sont dur qui s'engagent tous les
matins pour aller au boulot c'est des
métiers difficiles ils sont à 1007 ils
sont à 1008 ils sont à 2000 voilà qui
sont
trop je suis d'accord moment doné moi
pour moi je vous dis la politique pour
moi j'ai déjà dit ici ça devitêtre de la
conviction à 4 5000 € par mois tu
peuxé lu répondre 15900 € par MO bien sû
c'est un salaire exceptionnel mais
sache-le si
gabrielalou
gag a pas chois premier ministreemuel
MACR dire aur été dans la finance ou
dans le privé dire qu'il a ils auraient
gagné je te le dis he c'est des 100000
pas la question parce qu'ils iront après
après quand ils sortiront de ce métier
là ils feront des conférences ils en
feront Nicolas Sarkozi fait des
conférences François Hollande va
peut-être faire des conférences les
anciens présidents les anciens les
anciens ministres après font des
conférences donc sils font ça aussi
c'est aussi une belle vitrine pour eux
vous me demandez mon avis 15000 c'est
trop mais tu parles de ceux qui sont qui
sont souspayés par rapport à Gabriel il
y en a beaucoup qui sont surpayés aussi
par rapport à ce qu'ils font et nous les
premers
pr VI de
dire ça veut dire que pour ce serait
quoi pour toi un
salaire 4 5000 balles tu peux avoir
autant de
conviction plein de gens qui
s'engageront pas en politique par pas
convictionors quand
VI de conviction du P pourquoi tu crois
qu'il font des allersretours dans le
privé parce que justement ils ont besoin
à un moment donné d'avoir un petit peu
d'argent la présidente de France
Télévision c'est 400000 € par
an mon
argument do gagner au moins 4 ou
que P pour la présid celui qui touche
1800 € celui qui touche 1800 € il va
payer pour quelqu'un qui métier qui va
faire combien de
temps s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
Martin qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ben
il faut aussi ramener ça au volume
horaire que ça représente c'estd que
évidemment ce sont des métiers ce serait
un indescent de dire que c'est mal payé
par rapport à ce que gagne un franç
moyen c'est très très bien payé il faut
aussi le ramener à la réalité aussi de
la vie que ça que ça fait c'est-à-dire
c'est des horaires vous n'avez pas
d'horair surtout quand vous faites votre
métier en l'occurrence ministre et
Premier ministre encore plus c'est comme
le fait Gabri
c'est du H 2 vous demandz fris
français français
don vont pas
faire
che il est là il a une énorme
responsabilité enc he Payette somme pay
3000 €c ilain de four appelle-moi le 24
décembre 15000 B je vais te
rére apr moi je trouve que c'est humain
de vouloir comparer parce que bah on a
envie de le faire mais j'ai envie de
dire à contrario que c'est pas
comparable quand même une prestance
quelque chose qu'on veut voir c'est
quelqu'un qui nous représente c'est
après justement en disant que c'est
quelqu'un qui nous représente moi je
veux bien qu'il soit payé 15 100 € 20000
€ SS veulent c'est pas mon problème par
contre soyez efficace je ve pas vous
voir en train de boire de la bière en
T-shirt je ve pas vous voir sur TikTok
je pas vous voir en train de danser avec
des plumes où je pense et cetera là par
contre faut rester en costume il faut
travailler et être effectif et
C elle sort les gripes C c'est vrai à ce
moment on veut voir le retour
et mariehélène vous avez eu un autre je
crois vous avez Benjamin Castaldi aussi
absolument j'ai eu Benjamin en
6e de trajectoire trajoire vous
compreniez ce qu'il disait à l'école
trajo
TR de élèves non mais c'est c'est
l'école c'est c'est l'École alsacienne
j'ai eu des élèves de de tous niveaux de
qui ont fait des des carrières dans des
mondes très différents les uns des
autres c'est fou et je dis c'est une
réussite de l'école de permettre à
chaque élève finalement de faire euh ce
qu'il veut faire et ce qu'il est capable
de faire - dit travais bien il avait un
peu de
[Applaudissements]
difficultéérér elle est genre d'autre
commelè est- mais c'est un enfant très
gentil mais il avait un peu de
difficulté je trouve que pourquoi pour
pourquoi être malhonnête autant dire les
choses Mar est-ce que vous avez même de
gens pas connu des élèves qui ont fait
des carrières exceptionnelles qui ont
voilà qui ont qui ont des des des qui
ont des grosses réussites non mais je ne
citerai personne non mais non sans cité
bien sûr j'ai des élèves qui ont fait
des carrières extrêmement brillantes
mais pas je vous dis pas dans seulement
dans la
politique dans le notamment dans les la
culture dans vous avez qu'à prendre la
liste l'annuaire des anciens élèves de
l'école et vous verrez ouis c'est c'est
fort donc évidemment comme j'enseigé 23
ans à l'école j'en ai vu quelquesuns
bien sûr franchement fort hein euh vous
pensez que il va réussir au poste de
Premier ministre Martin Gabriel Atal ou
pas ben c'est quelqu'un qui s'engage à
fond et d'ailleurs vous avez pu le le
remarquer il n'a pas fait campagne pour
devenir Premier ministre contrairement à
d'autres noms qui circulaient depuis des
mois et des mois gamer latal il est dans
l'action il est au jour le jour et
d'ailleurs désol enfin il nous a quitté
après la passation on a eu un échange
amical avec lui en petit comité juste
après il est tout de suite parti pour se
rendre dans le Nord P de calé pour être
au chevet des victimes des inondations
donc c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui est
toujours dans l'action qui fait pas
semblant euh et je je lui souhaite et je
nous souhaite de qu'il soit à la hauteur
de la mission et qu'il la remplisse le
mieux possible parce que c'est dans
l'intérêt collectif évidemment Benjamin
castadie qui vous
embrasse salut non vient de m'écrire il
me dit voilà il m'a dit c'était ma prove
d'histoire quand j'étais à l'cienne j'ai
pas fini premier
ministre drôle on le savait hein c'était
pas la peine de nous le dire hein oui
patri moi j'avais une question pour
Madame est-ce que vous souvenez d'un
d'un devoir marquant de Gabri est-
wouh ça c'est franchement quelqu'un qui
va faire une énorme carrière il est il
faisait de bonnes copies tout était
brillant il y avait pas mais je veux
dire j'ai eu aussi d'autres élèves qui
faisaient de bonnes copies et comme je
ne je je n'archive pas les copies de mes
élèves quel qu'elles soit j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a un déséquilibre
dans l'amour entre vous non non
non non mais c'est vra non il a lui
c'est fou qu'il est vous qui vous a cité
quand même mais non mais c'est
incroyable mais vous j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a plein d'élèves non mais de
manièreologique elle est
vra quoi bah de manière trè logique elle
était seule et elle elle était avec
plein de personnes oui c'est ça attends
attends qu'est-ce que tu veux
dire
manière c'est comme vous c'est comme
vous vous m'aimez et moi je vous
aime
ex j'ai compris moi je vous dis il a
aucune hiérarchie tous au même niveau
mais tous au même niveau ah mais
vraiment je vous aime tous au
déteste appelez-moi à 4h du matin si
vous avez un gros problème vous verrez
si je
réponds oui est-ce qu'on peut poser
encore une question bien sûr avec grand
plaisir alors euh quand il est arrivé au
ministère de l'Éducation nationale
Gabriel hatal a fait du de la du
harcèlement scolaire un de ses
principaux combats et il a dit justement
qu'à titre personnel ça lui était arrivé
et qu'il en avait souffert est-ce que
c'était justement en Première et en
terminale et est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est donc une époque qui a changé parce
que aujourd'hui maintenant un élève qui
serait avec vous victime de harcèlement
il viendrait vous voir il viendrait vous
en parler est-ce que justement les
choses ont évolué oui les choses ont
évolué les les réseaux étaient pas
organisés comme aujourd'hui il y avait
pas les mêmes moyens ça se passait plus
en dehors de l'école bon il y avait des
rivalités entre jeunes comme il y en a
partout hein prenez une cours de
récréation je parle même pas des jeunes
je parle des des tout petits enfants
s'il avait pas des adultes pour les les
encadrer c'est c'est c'est c'est ce
serait la foire d'empoigne he absolument
donc effectivement moi je n'étais pas au
courant
euh mais je crois que c'est un un mal
qui a été général et qui s'est quand
même beaucoup aent tué je pense beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup oui très bien ben oui
qu'est-ce veux j'ai une question pour
Martin si c'est possible oui ben rap
rapidement on dit le reproche qu'on lui
fait parfois c'est que c'est un
solitaire il travaille ses dossiers mais
il fonce il est seul et il a pas
d'équipe est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous avez vécu aussi avec lui sa
solitude dans l'exercice du pouvoir
alors pour de B expérience c'est
exactement le contraire il a par exemple
dans son équipe au cabinet du ministère
il a exactement les mêmes personnes qui
le suivent depuis le son premier poste
ministériel ce qui monre à fois fidélité
un engagement une solidité des des liens
après la politique c'est de la confiance
mais moi pour avoir fait plusieurs
campagnes sur le terrain avec lui c'est
quelqu'un que au contraire qui est très
très entouré qui est très très à
l'écoute et qui fait pas semblant comme
certains peuvent le faire c'est-à-dire
que il écoute et après il apporte des
solutions voilà bien fait pour ta
tronche merci Martin merci merci
marie-élène d'avoir été avec nous et
vraiment si je reprends les cours
j'aimerais bien vous avoir vous pouvez
m'interroger en histoire allez-y
interrogz-moiy interroger en histoire
question interrog-mo histoire interog
uneè Mar Mar arê Mar alors marign ça se
trouve où ti marign ça se trouve Italie
bravo Italie bravo par en a plein qui
croyent que c'était dans le sud de la
France oui Mar Mar est-ce que vous avez
une question pour moi Marie-Hélène une
question histoire une question
d'histoireou queavis pas je suis en
train de chercher une question
[Rires]
difficile
Lay
la crise de Cuba café ou Cuba connais 62
Cuba cab gringo la crise de Cuba
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que justement
ce que vous savez la date déjà la date
déjà la date
déjà2 je vais remettre quand même mon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oreillette je sais très bien que c en
1962 merci
c'est toujours sympa voilà de faire
genre qu'on sait
pas tout le monde
rigole
question'est-il qu'est-ce qu'il y a
qu'est-ce que vous
dites 16 octobre ça a commencéou ça
commencé 16 octobre merci marieélèine
d'avoir été avec nous et merci Martin
merci d' allez